سيكون من الخطأ الفادح
أن تعتقد أي دولة أن الخطر قد
تجاوز
الاستخدام المصمم والمتسق
لتدابير الصحة العامة
جنبًا إلى جنب مع
التطعيم
العادل ،
لذا فإن أرقام التطعيم في الولايات المتحدة تبدو
جيدة وليست رائعة ولكنها تبدو جيدة جدًا.
الانفتاح في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
ما هو قلقك الذي تعتقد أنه
ينطبق علينا ، ما هي رسالتك
إلى الأشخاص الذين يشعرون
بالرجولة الجيدة على الشاطئ في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
والتي تنطبق تمامًا على الولايات المتحدة
، وهي حقًا
تقلقني وتخيفني لأننا نعتقد
أننا منعزلون ، نعتقد أنه لمجرد أن
الأمور أفضل هنا ،
فقد انتهى الأمر وأنا أتفق مع
المدير العام في أن هذا سيكون
خطأ فادحًا
، فلنواجه الأمر ، فمن
المحتمل أن يمتد هذا الوباء لسنتين أخريين
على الأقل في سنة واحدة  بطريقة أو بأخرى ،
ومجرد توقفها عن الرش هنا في
الولايات المتحدة لا يعني ذلك أنه
لا توجد سحب عاصفة في الأفق  نحن
موجودون وحتى يتم احتواء هذا الأمر في جميع البلدان على
محمل الجد ،
لا يوجد بلد آمن
لأننا لسنا معزولين ، نسافر هناك
تجارة ،
لذا فهو خطأ فادح خاصة
عندما تكون لدينا هذه الفرصة لأخذ
اللقاحات وحماية أنفسنا
والعديد من الناس كذلك  عدم
الاستفادة من
ذلك ، إنه مجرد جنون وأنه
خطأ في
غضون عامين آخرين ، وهذا ما
سمعته فقط تقول إن هذا
سيستمر لمدة عامين آخرين ،
تفضل بالمضي قدمًا
وأنت تعلم أنني كنت ذاهبًا إلى  أقول بطريقة
أو بأخرى ، أعني أننا نستمر في التفكير في
أن الولايات المتحدة
فقط هي الدول
التي تعرف تمامًا أنها تنفجر تمامًا مع
الطمع وسيسافر الناس
إلى أجزاء أخرى من البلاد
وإلى بلدان أخرى ، لذا استمع  ما لم
يقرر هذا الفيروس أن
يتبخر في الهواء يومًا ما ،
فإننا ننظر إلى حرق بطيء
ولدينا الفرصة لاحتوائه على الأقل
في هذا
البلد ونحتاج إلى مشاركة ذلك  الصحة مع
الدول الأقل حظًا حتى
تتمكن من احتوائها حتى نكون آمنين